okay here's the question I have what's
your guys's end goal
yeah I haven't got an end goal I just
want to create stuff right now that's
right you just want to create a stop and
lost forever not even forever I think I
think being creative is a momentary
thing I think not everyone gets to be an
artist that gets to survive generations
of course yeah I think just making stuff
that keeps people happy for a little
while is more than enough
and go I've reached my end goal you're
married I got married I have given my
parents a stable life which is all I
wanted to do uh that's the end goal for
me quitting my jobs do YouTube so um see
that's why my man is a [__] horse
and you're like I will not die until I
swim in a pool so I'm not gonna like I'm
not I'm not gonna retire tomorrow but
I'm like
I'm satisfied I but you need to do
something that's that's the thing you
probably have some like you you probably
have some things where you're just like
no I still haven't done that yet yeah
like I have big projects that I really
really want to do that I'm working on
right now but in terms of like
my end goal and going sounds like
[__] just like what I did this for
originally yeah I reached that and I'm
like very very happy to have done that
so now I'm just like even if the stuff I
do in the future fails I'm like I've
already done what I wanted to do I'm a
very simple man uh which is why I'm just
like I am content which is why
as long as the people around me are
happy no matter what I'll be happy yeah
oh yeah that's that's just me that's me
being [__] drunk I mean I saw like uh
Twitter post it was like there is no
benefit to being a good human being
um wait who said that I was on Twitter I
was doing already it was doing very well
yeah well yeah I mean technically we're
talking about like how you advance and
manipulate yeah of course there's
nothing inherently beneficial to being
good people but yeah your entire worth
as a human being when you realize hey
helping people feels great yeah being a
part of someone's Journey getting
involved absolutely yeah it's easy to be
skeptical uh but I think being
successful means being able to help
those around you and help them
unconditionally and get something very
absolutely [__] respecting respect
for you for doing all the [__]
charity stuff yeah man I appreciate it
well I mean that was like that was
something that kind of you know I I it
wasn't like I consciously decided to do
it I wish I could be better and be like
yeah of course I wanted to do it yeah
you know it just turned out that the
thing's all lined up you know it kind of
I found a good cause yeah I felt I felt
like I really wanted to help Mouse in
that aspect yeah and uh you know I felt
like
you know I think it's safe to say we
we've all three of us have made a good
amount of money like I feel like we're
doing okay like we're good like I
I'm fine monetarily like I don't need to
make x amount of money a month like I
could I'm fine for for a good little
while I can't live the rest of my life
but like in this very moment with the
amount of making I'm good yeah so I was
like I just kind of looked and I was
like
it just makes no more sense to do
anything for for me it felt like there
wasn't much sense to do projects that
were full profit Also let's make
something creative maybe make a little
bit of money on the side but let's make
the main focus making money for good
causes yeah yeah because like why the
[__] not yeah like let's just absolutely
like I just for me it felt like the
right thing to do and I get it that now
for everyone it doesn't feel that way uh
and I would never press any creators
into doing any charity stuff because
like I feel like if your heart's not it
you shouldn't do it yeah obviously it
still helps voluntarily but like I think
if you really really want to get people
invested yeah and raise money and get
people involved
I think you've got to be your heart's
gonna be in it yeah and I think that was
the problem I had before is that like I
just didn't feel there was a charity
that I really connected with there was a
few that I I like the idea of but I yeah
I mean we all like charity and we all
like the idea of it but let's be real a
lot of us you don't care like a lot of
us aren't connected to it because and I
think rightfully so we all care about
how the [__] we're doing yeah a lot of
us are struggling I think a lot of the
viewers at home are not not doing too
well you're going through something and
I think it's totally valid to care about
what you're going through and what you
what you're doing uh but I think when
you get to a point financially where
you're very stable you have to kind of
be like all right there's going more to
it there's gonna be more to what I'm
doing yeah and there's got to be a way I
can give back yeah and I think doing
that is very important when you have a
platform yeah um I really really mean
that I I mean I totally agree with you
uh I I'd say when I was younger I would
probably you hear about resno Red Nose
Day all these Charities or whatever it
is I would probably be the type of
person that would like that tweet that
you saw and like yeah me too you know
because they're all merits you do you
will climb a lot faster if you don't
honestly you look at some of some of the
people now that are successful you're
like these are all horrible people and
what has Society taught us that horrible
people uh climb uh if you want to be
successful you be the loudest and you be
the person who shouts the loudest yeah
and you will get attention and uh most
of the time you'll be successful and I'm
like okay well that's well that's how
Society is like
uh that's that's how Society is like
structured at least right now where the
people who shout loudest get the most
attention and the people get the most
attention normally now make the most
money you know that's not always the
sense but it is I mean more views more
money yeah
you know it's unfortunate that charity
is kind of you know I mean I feel like
almost
I I don't know if this is true but it
feels like credit is do less stuff by
charity now than ever I don't know why I
feel that way I will tell you why
uh because by doing charity but okay
look at someone like Mr Beast for
example yeah okay I I generally think Mr
Beast is doing something positive for
the world but by getting a lot of time
by getting a lot of eyes on you by doing
something positive you are actually
putting yourself at risk that's so funny
because because it's [__] up that even
if you do something like net positive
Goods people will try to poke holes and
people will try to find like nefarious
yeah he's like he's just doing it for
attention yeah you know he's doing it
because he wants to make himself look
like a person which you can't deny that
there there is an aspect of that not
like there is an aspect of doing
something good gets your attention
so there's all other celebrities that we
feel yeah disingenuous yeah yeah exactly
but it's it sucks that when you try to
do something good sometimes that gives
you more attention and more eyes on you
and more people criticizing you because
you are trying to do something good for
the world as opposed to doing something
for profit or doing something yeah
I firmly believe that every Creator is
well off
um should be doing charity stuff at
least once a year or something
um
but I I also understand that that motive
yeah like you said you get too big from
doing it yeah what not I think the hard
part is that and I realized this through
myself is that
um it's hard
to really sell a charity to your viewers
if there's not some kind of personal
story there and it kind of sucks but
like you know when you see these these
ads about oh every five seconds a kid
dies or something and we're so
desensitized we are we are so [__]
sensitized and then we you know and and
that was because that was attractive for
a very long time yeah and I imagine it
worked at some point but it doesn't work
anymore because we just don't care like
yeah and I think it's fair to say that's
where we're at yeah and so I think as
creators there needs to be some kind of
personal connection but it's kind of
tough because obviously maybe we're all
young and we don't have these
connections to X charity because we
don't have any experience with them yeah
so I think as a Creator you you need to
almost look for a cause to kind of be
passionate about and get excited about
because I think also your viewership
will also appreciate that you're excited
about raising money for a good call
viewers are very very smart if you do
not care about something they can tell
yeah you've got you got you guys are
smart doesn't really like that dick but
like you know occasionally there'll be a
thing and not must be like this charity
but this does happen a lot like they'll
be like people like yeah yeah cancer
research you're like okay yeah all right
I get it like that's a very very very
common disease it takes a lot of lives
yeah but I think to a lot of people that
seems almost disingenuous because it's
kind of like you don't have a personal
story and it sucks it has to be the case
but I think for for people that almost
needs to be a personal story or a
connection to sell people on why you
care so much about this I think almost
picking some generic stuff you know even
you know even though like uh sometimes
you see like mental health stuff it's
like oh it's almost too broad reaching
sometimes and I think it's kind of tough
because we're in this age now where
you're almost pressured into caring too
much about a subject or a specific kind
of illness yeah um and I've learned that
a lot through through working with uh
with what I've been doing I've learned
that that having that really specific
story has been very very good for
getting people involved and caring about
it which sucks because if maybe if I
cared about it and I didn't have a
personal connection I might not be able
to sell people as much right yeah do you
know what sucks about that because I've
gone through like this very similar
thing where I'm I wear it's just like I
have you want to do something I have
these certain things that I care about
that has affected my family and [__]
like that yeah but I've like for example
I've never talked about it on trash
taste because it's a very like personal
thing I've never kind of like you know
really talked about it publicly so I
know to like an audience is you're just
gonna like come out left field right you
know and it's just like it it sucks that
when you are doing something good like
charity you need to prove that you care
about this stuff I mean I think it's
because there's so many disingenuous
scenarios yeah yeah people don't and
that's and that's the [__] issue
where there is so many like bad eggs in
the world that try to take advantage of
people try to like
take advantage and do whatever to make
themselves look good that I'm that it's
just made it so much harder to actually
like try to do good in this world holy
[__] we are so drunk because this is a
romantic [__] talk right now